c'est l'une des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire et économique du covic 19 avec
moins d'embauchés cet été certains
étudiants se retrouvent fragilisés
financièrement pour la rentrée scolaire
cette difficulté s'ajoute à une
précarité étudiante présentes depuis
longtemps déjà en 1961
yves un étudiant de 20 ans expliquer ces
conditions de vie précaires un
journaliste ne valait pas chauffer on se
couvre a rappelé avec les couvertures de
lui à l'époque le témoignage est rare le
problème de la précarité étudiante est
peu médiatisé pourtant ils existent en
même constat tous les soirs depuis trois
ans
roger est obligé de travailler comme
chauffeur pour payer son école vous êtes
heureux et bien non
années 80 c'est toujours le même
problème en 1982 selon une étude 60 %
des étudiants vivaient avec moins de
1000 francs par mois c'est le cas de
fazia étudiante à paris dont le revenu
mensuel atteignez les 650 francs après
avoir payé le loyer par exemple après
avoir payé la bouffe après avoir payé
les transports la carte orange
après tous ces frais là bas il nous
reste plus grand-chose années 90 la
population étudiante s'appauvrit encore
elle se paupérise
en cause notamment des frais
d'inscription élevés mais aussi des
universitaires de plus en plus nombreux
j'avais une grosse d'à peu près 18
francs et l'âge comme j'ai retrouvé ma
première année maj l'épervier maintenant
j'ai plus rien une demande des
d'exceptionnel et même si jean-pierre
cette aide je n'aurai pas le montant de
ma bourse
il faut attendre les années 2000 pour
que le sujet soit plus présent dans les
médias
exemple en 2007 pour cet étudiant en
mathématiques
les fins de mois sont très difficiles
après les dépenses courantes
il ne lui restait que 19 euros pour
vivre on peut pas s'acheter de la viande
tous les jours moi je tire le repas de
base c'est les pattes
même les des choix de santé parce qu'à
aller consulter un médecin mons est
effectivement on est couvert on à la
sécurité à la sécurité sociale étudiante
donc ça c'est très bien mais avant ces
50 euros un spécialiste parce qu'on a un
problème de vente depuis deux semaines
sa planète une en bourse- enfin moi il
peut pas le faire cette année la crise
sanitaire et économique du coc vite 19
aura un impact supplémentaire sur la
précarité des étudiants de nouvelles
dépenses sont à prévoir comme les
masques ou les gels hydro-alcooliques
[Musique]